in Southern California firefighters are
battling another dangerous wildfire
southeast of Los Angeles the canyon to
fire has destroyed at least two dozen
structures in Anaheim more than 5,000
homes have been evacuated
mark Strassmann is in Anaheim Hills
where several houses burned mark good
morning good morning this house is gone
the flames got in the attic and up it
went on this cul-de-sac five homes went
up in about three hours right now the
fire is burning on a ridge about four
miles in that direction and at last
estimate it was only five percent
contained the fire was visible for miles
as a tour through suburban neighborhoods
reducing homes to piles of smoldering
wood and ash 1,000 firefighters in
Southern California are working to put
out the flames from the ground and from
above nearly two dozen helicopters and
other aircraft have been using water
drops gusts up to 45 miles per hour and
low humidity have fueled the flames
making conditions more difficult for
first responders we're hoping that the
weather goes in our favor but if not
we're continuing to fight this at nearby
Disneyland park goers captured the eerie
skies glowing a bright orange the heavy
smoke turned the Sun into a small red
dot evacuations were ordered for more
than 5,000 homes but some people chose
to stay behind it's never the same we
may be able to be rebuild them but I
just can't imagine losing your home
especially in this manner kevin Chaffetz
and his family left two hours before the
fire crept over the hillside and
engulfed his home it's pretty surreal
you know I'll probably try and handle
this the best I can for now and then
deal with it emotionally a couple months
down the road firefighters will battle
tough conditions again today high wind
gusts low humidity evacuation orders and
neighborhoods like this will remain in
place but the worry here is that the
fire is going to take more homes today
Charlie thanks mark